comment ça va comment vous allez
aujourd'hui bien ou bien bien alors
regardez aujourd'hui on parle de ça ça
c'est la nouvelle montre de mode veille
non connectés c'est la tique watts
proden il va je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez on va retourner deux ans en
arrière on retourne en 2018 vous
présenter la ticad pro qui est une
montre et d'ailleurs qui est et qui dit
retour du monde collecter des mots boys
je suis vraiment mais vraiment vraiment
vraiment agréablement satisfait modèle
très intéressant pourquoi parce que en
fait vous aviez deux et vous avez
toujours deux écrans superposés un écran
lcd pour un aspect plus économies
d'énergie avec des informations
essentielles et pas plus et de l'autre
côté vous avez un écran amoled avec de
la couleur vous et pouvoir faire plein
de choses est plus dans l'idée de la
monde connecté telle qu'on la connaît un
petit peu classiquement le fait d'avoir
ces deux écrans de parité de basculer
d'un mode à l'autre de façon hybride
intelligent d'avoir une très grosse
autonomie que c'était toute la promesse
est tout l'intérêt satie quoi je
trouvais justement en 2020 il vient
beauvois est revenu avec une nouvelle
version de satie quest pro qui coassent
pro 2020 et on reprend exactement
exactement la même confie en allant plus
loin on va avoir une certification il
fait 68 ans avant une certification
militaire enfin avoir un modèle qui va
être plus robuste qui a aussi ses
limites qui a aussi ses défauts je vais
tous vous exposer et je vais vous dire
si c'est le modèle la 7e' cointreau 2020
est fait pour vous parce qu'elle est
proposée à un tarif intéressante par
rapport à tout pour trouver à la
concurrence à configuration équivalente
voilà ça c'est beau c'est joli mais
juste avant et si ce n'est pas déjà le
cas vous invite à venir à cliquer en
dessous la sueur petit bouton rouge vous
vous abonnez oui pourquoi
parce que bien évidemment parle de
mondes connectés on parle de smartphones
de tablettes ordinateurs de bonnes
choses de votre vie numérique et je
parle également de vous de vos usages
est-ce qu'il faut dormir à cause de son
smartphone est ce que c'est dangereux
je vous parle de ça y est je vous
parlais de plein de choses de plein de
choses il ya des guides d'achat des
tutos enfin c'est extraordinaire on
complique là on s'abonne comme ça au
moins vous saurez tout et vous activer
la cloche comme ça vous serez notifié
dès qu'une nouvelle vidéo arrivera voilà
la boîte tic watch pro 2020 principe du
packaging plutôt bien élégant
on va passer extrêmement rapidement là
dessus parce qu'il ya pas grand grand
grand chose à venir raconté lorsque vous
l'ouvrez vous retrouvez une fois de plus
qui quoique je crois comme ça vous la
levée alors la montre est déjà à mon
poignet elle est bien évidemment pas
présent dedans vous retrouvez votre
montre ici là vous avez toutes vos
petites informations dans plein de
langues donc si vous avez envie d'avoir
un peu
sûr et puis d'apprendre les langues et
bien coûter pourquoi pas et vous avez
également le petit bloc de charge qui
vient là qui vient se charger en usb et
en fait c'est extrêmement pratique
puisque pour venir le recharger prenez
votre montre vous mettez les connecteurs
en face c'est aimante et ça tient tout
seul parlons maintenant de la montre en
elle même alors la montre moi je la
trouve plutôt sympa pourquoi déjà parce
que vous avez un côté très premium avec
ce bracelet en cuir cuir d'un côté
silicone de l'autre pour avoir beaucoup
de confort ça c'est plutôt bien
on est vraiment se rendre à ces les
standards donc vous venez de prendre
vous le refermer comme un bras c'est
classique
on vient pas se coincer les poils ici
donc ça c'est bien et croyez moi dans
mon cas et bien c'est quand même
relativement pratique vous trouvez en
plus ici un petit crantage la regarder
voyez je vais pouvoir me reloger
cette partie là pour le faire mais très
facilement aux points qui est
intéressant c'est comme vous avez un
bracelet en silicone à l'intérieur ça va
être pratique lorsque vous aller
transpirer pour la sueur lorsque vous
allez faire du sport donc le fait
d'avoir ces matériaux hybrides donne à
la fois un côté premium à côté pratique
pour le sport donc ça s'est vraiment
bien le boîtier est en fibre de carbone
renforcée par du nylon de haute
résistance
on a un produit ici qu'il ya répondre
aux standards militaires qui résiste à
des températures je peux dire extrêmes
mais presque de -20° à + 55 degrés une
montée certifié ip 68 il va donc être
résistantes à la poussière mais
également à l'eau et vous avez un verre
corning gorilla glass 300 votes monde
autant dire que le produit va être au
but ça c'est bien facile à porter c'est
vraiment le côté très positif de la
chose maintenant direct le côté un peu
négative de la chose si on peut parler
comme ça c'est qu'on a une montre qui
est quand même assez épaisse ça dépend
bien évidemment de vous de vos goûts si
vous aimez les grands boîtier un petit
peu lâches ou si vous préférez les
choses un peu plus plate un peu plus
discrète mais si vous voulez quelque
chose de très discret plutôt petit et
bien c'est pas sur cette montre là qu'il
faut aller si par contre le fait d'avoir
ce gros boîtier un peu épais ne vous
dérange pas eh bien il se peut que la
cucquoise pro 2020 soit faite pour vous
par contre lorsque vous l'avez au
poignet on est unique et vraiment sympa
très élégante très urbaine
vous pouvez venir en plus retirer votre
bracelet si vous le souhaitez et venir
le changer sans aucun problème donc ça
ça marche
lorsque vous l'avez comme ça et bien
vous avez une information sur l'écran
lcd sais pas si vous le voyez bien comme
ça on à l'heure on a la date on va voir
le nombre de patients souhaitent et vous
venez appuyer dessus vous venez l'activé
là vous passez sur l'écran amoled
après on tombe sur un os de google tout
ce qui est plus classique sur le haut
vous avez tous vos paramètres mode avion
google paye parce que oui on peut si
vous avez du nfc dont vous pouvez payer
grâce à google paye ça c'est très bien
pour venir retrouver votre smartphone en
appuyant
pour moi il est dans ma poche donc
forcément on l'entend c'est très
pratique vos paramètres bien évidemment
ici on sait duroueix 50 ans darche pas
si vous connaissez bien vous avez
beaucoup d'écrans pour venir paramétrer
vous pouvez en télécharger énormément il
y en a plus de 1000 je vous passe un
petit peu le côté ouest parce que ça va
forcément ce qui va nous intéresser
aujourd'hui geste connectivité bon
faisait pas mal de possibilités sur le
côté gauche j'ai retrouvé toutes vos
notifications sur la partie droite et
bien vous avez le côté sport vous avez
la météo la voyage un rendez vous une
courbe de shlomi qui débute tout à
l'heure sur la partie du bas vous allez
retrouver les notifications vous allez
retrouver plein d'applications bien
évidemment sur le ps store et ça c'est
vraiment très très bien notamment les
applications recommandées pour vous je
vous passe le côté un peu pratique
spotify télégramme les compagnies y en a
plein de tous les côtés ce qui fait que
je viens pas mal d'applications qui sont
installés notamment les applications de
respiration dans des applications de
sport bring pour ma liste de courses mon
chrono mais google fit exercice si
google paye pour venir payer
effectivement grâce au nfc sajoo et déjà
dit de la météo et après si je veux
passer sur le mode essentiels eh bien
voyez ça situe juste là j'appuie pour
passer en mode essentiel est là je
retrouve dans la configuration je dirais
la plus standard peu appuyée par tous
faire ce que je veux ma montre est en
mode est essentielle si je reste avant
essentielles pures nam on peut m'emmener
jusqu'à 30 jours d'autonomie alors
effectivement on va dire je ne me
connecte et j'ai trente jours c'est bien
mais j'ai pas grand chose qui va
s'afficher c'est un peu les limites
l'idée c'est plutôt usage mixte puisque
si j'utilise tout le temps avec mon
écran amoled je vais avoir une autonomie
allant jusqu'à deux jours mais sur un
usage mixte et bien fait passer de deux
jours à 5 jours ce qui fait que
conserver maman trois jours et demi
quatre jours extrêmement facilement en
portions bien évidemment une fête plus
de l'usaj que vous allez en avoir mais
quand on sait qu'une monde connecté on
va pas utiliser autant qu'un smartphone
à être dessus et bien vous allez pouvoir
emmener l'autonomie un peu plus loin et
ça je trouve vraiment intéressant
exactement cette proposition où on va
avoir un écran de bonne qualité puisque
ici vous avez un écran amoled 400 pixels
par 400 pixels un écran de 1,39 pouces
avec un affichage amoled ftn est de
notre côté cette autonomie qui est très
bonne avec une batterie de 415 millions
terreur on a donc un combo qui est
parfait qui est intelligent qui est bien
maîtrisée un deuxième bouton plus sur le
bas vous allez pouvoir venir assignés à
ce que vous voulez alors ici il est
assigné à la partie sport de google pour
avoir de la marche extérieure jeu pour
faire la course en arrière pour en faire
du vélo en termes de performance vous
avez rien de bien
surprenant ici vous avez un qualcomm
snapdragon were 2101 giga de ram 4 gigas
de stockage vous allez voir une
connexion bluetooth en bluetooth 4
points 2 une montre qui a aussi un gps
intégré donc lorsque vous allez faire
des sessions de sport à l'extérieur ça
fonctionnera du wifi pour la connecter
directement mais ici par contre pas de
4g donc si vous voulez de la data si
vous voulez des informations vous allez
devoir avoir toujours votre smartphone à
côté de vous à savoir cette montre elle
fonctionne aussi bien avec android que
ios
côté capteur on a un podomètre on a un
cardiofréquencemètre cette montre a
aussi un compteur de calories
un moniteur de cadence et une vitesse
bien évidemment accéléromètre gyroscope
point qui est important à mentionner
c'est que la visibilité est très bonne
lorsque vous êtes en plein soleil en
extérieur néanmoins si vous voulez
pousser un peu plus vous mettez sur cinq
est là ça va venir taper énormément
alors j'ai plus beaucoup de batteries
donc mois à venir baisser et je vais me
mettre en automatique s'ajustera par
rapport à la lumière ambiante
autre point qui est bien c'est que vous
avez google assistant d'intégrer pour
google qui est le président de la
république française alors moi y'a un
truc que j'ai remarqué que j'ai trouvé
un petit peu bizarre c'est que lorsque
j'ai touché mon cadran à la tarière
voyez c'est équivaut à le faire un petit
sourire sur le côté et quel que soit
l'endroit que ce soit ici que ce soit
ici j'ai vu nulle part d'informations ce
que ce soit sur le site de mode vol dans
d'autres review est ce que c'est un bug
ça me paraît très surprenant est ce que
c'est un raccourci lorsque vous allez
faire du sport pour avoir accès
directement à vos infos en tout cas dans
l'absolu je trouve ça intéressant le
seul truc c'est quand que vous allez
venir glisser comme ça et bien vous ne
trouvez pas vos informations sur le côté
faut prendre un peu le coup mais ce bond
en libye et pourquoi pas votre côté un
peu pratique vous et des mouvements pour
venir naviguer up se passe dans ce sens
voyez ça ne descend les uns après les
autres de l'extérieur vers l'intérieur
mais également de l'intérieur à
l'extérieur il ya un petit coup à
prendre au niveau de la gestion de votre
poignet mais bon ça fonctionne très très
très bien vous pouvez répondre aux
appels téléphoniques en appuyant là par
contre ça va répondre directement sur
votre iphone et vous devrez prendre
ensuite l'appelle directement sur votre
téléphone
sans quoi ça ne marchera pas et ça ça
vaut aussi bien pour ios que pour
android
concernant les sms une différence entre
à ios et android par exemple sur android
du pouvoir ouvrir mon message je pouvoir
envoyer un petit oui non ok où je peux
carrément répondre
coucou toi sarko et mon message je
valide le message est envoyé tandis que
ça je peux absolument pas le faire sur
ios c'est pour moi la vraie grosse
différence majeure
et qu'on était en termes de tarifs c'est
une montre que vous pouvez retrouver au
tarif de 259 euros avec 99 centimes si
elle vous intéresse d'ailleurs je vous
ai mis un lien en bas dans la discrétion
pour aller cliquer comme ça vous saurez
tout j'aime bien la proposition que fait
une offre vol sur sa montre le fait de
l'avoir réactualisée sur une version
2020 et bien dans l'absolu pourquoi pas
qu'est ce que ça va porter cette
nouvelle version de 2020 par rapport à
la version antérieure
on va avoir une certification militaire
aucune autre camp plus résistantes qui
va être un parent l'épreuve du temps en
tout cas à l'épreuve des chocs des
chutes des frottements de la pluie donc
un produit que les pouvoir emmener
partout avec vous facilement garde
toujours un design qui est très sympa
bracelet je voulais dit l'inconvénient
c'est qu'elle est un peu épaisses le
deuxième inconvénient c'est que si vous
n'avez pas de 4g c'est pas non plus
changer quelque chose qui est énormément
démocratiser sur les mondes connectés
toutes les montres ne sont pas connectés
à la 4g et encore moins à la 5g
donc si vous voulez une monde connecté
qui fonctionne bien bonne qualité avec
where os de google
et bien cette montre la de mode vont y
est très cool je compte sur vous pour
dire vous ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire m'a personnellement
j'aime bien c'est vrai que je trouve
qu'elle est un peu épaisses ça je vous
le dis je vous le redis une fois de plus
quand on est habitué à utiliser une
apple watch eh bien on va voir tout est
quelque chose qui est un peu surprenant
néanmoins on oublie assez rapidement
c'est une montre que je trouve malgré
tout de bonnes qualités de bonne facture
mais surtout et c'est pas le plus
important pour moi le fait d'avoir ce
double écran le fait d'avoir cette
grande autonomie c'est un point qui est
extrêmement fort aujourd'hui et rien que
pour ça très bon boulot mcevoy a vous de
me dire vous maintenant ce que vous en
pensez comment vous la trouvez lactique
watch pro 2020 est ce qu'elle peut vous
intéresser est ce que vous aviez déjà
acheté la tic aux pros en 2018 est-ce
que ce modèle là peut vous tentez oui
non pas comment vous marrer tout ça bien
évidemment on va aux commentaires à
notre goût et extrêmement rapidement
pour autrui par l'état qui croyez moi
même en été il ya beaucoup de choses à
raconter il ya beaucoup de l'enfant
produit beaucoup de nouveautés et ça
c'est très cool vous envoie ruhr
beaucoup d'amour prenez soin de vous et
à très vite
ciao ciao
[Musique]
non